[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
frank isola
the net studio host on yes sirius xm nba
radio the starting lineup host you can
also see him as a contributor
to around the horn pardon the
interruption frank was on site
at uh the nets game on saturday night as
we watched james harden make a
cameo appearance and then head to the
locker room
frank thanks for joining us uh what can
we expect with james harden or what did
you find out
about that injury yeah he lasted 43
seconds you didn't see him again
i thought it was interesting after the
game i once had a guy tell me when i
first started covering uh sports a guy
from the new york times he said
never under play an injury and after
games if a guy's not hurt the team will
always say it's not that bad
if it's a bad injury they'll always say
no we don't really know and after the
game that's what you were kind of
getting from the brooklyn nets and then
steve nash said
i'm heartbroken for james why would you
be heartbroken for him if he's going to
come back any time soon and kevin durant
made it seem like it's going to be a
long-term thing just remember this dan
when harden got same hamstring right a
hamstring injury
he was out from april 7th until may 12th
so that you know that should kind of
give you some indication of where this
could be
yeah i was wondering about that the
severity he knew right away but
i've said this the last couple of weeks
whether it was lebron's ankle
it was ads groin it was harden's
hamstring
these injuries don't go away they linger
you manage them maybe they cool down a
little bit
but if lebron kept playing that ankle
would be a problem at some point
in the playoffs and i think with anthony
davis the groin injury
was not going to go away and the same
thing with james harden
and i just don't know it sounded like
it's far more severe than then at least
it looked because he just sort of went
up
felt it i'm gone i don't know if he's
going to be out as long as he was before
because a lot of that could have been
just
precautionary yes but this is now
you know now you got the milwaukee bucks
and if the bucks win tonight
you know at some point you know can you
say to james harden
we need you i know but you know the
probably the most famous hamstring
injury in the playoffs i guess would be
magic when they played detroit when
detroit won its first title
and he was unable to play yeah i also
think you're right about the idea that
they did hold them out for that long
stretch because they knew
that they were sitting in a good
position they were either going to
finish second or third and that james
harden would eventually return i don't
know if we're going to see him again in
this series and that could be an issue
now mike james
who began the season in russia took
those minutes he played 30 minutes
in game one he had 12 points chris
middleton had 13.
so mike james coming off the bench a guy
that nobody's even heard of
you know did a really good job but i
wonder how to me they could still win
if it's kevin durant and kyrie irving
that's how good those two players are
but the road to winning a championship
just became that much harder for the
brooklyn nets we've been talking about
luka doncic
and that whatever that relationship or
lack thereof
is with kristaps porzingis you covered
him when he was with the knicks and he
was a big deal
literally and figuratively with the
knicks we thought tim hardaway jr was
the throw in on that trade
it feels like he's the better player out
of this like
what does dallas do with luca and is
kristaps porzingis going to be in that
equation
yeah i i would have to think there's a
possibility they could
look to move kristaps he needs to get
stronger not really his upper body
strength it really needs to be his core
because he gets pushed out of the block
too easily
defensively he's not strong enough yes
he can knock down shots
and if you look at what he did yesterday
his two pointers i think he ended up
going six for seven
on twos the problem was he could knock
down a three he needs to get better i
definitely think
there's a bit of a rivalry there and i
think kristaps needs to come to the
realization that luca is the star of the
team
i think we automatically assume well
they're two guys from europe so that
obviously they must get along i don't
think that's been the case you could see
the dynamic there
it's not great now you don't have to be
the best of friends
you know to be successful but on the
court
that chemistry isn't good between the
two of them the hawks take game one
if i said to the hawks you could do a
do-over and you get luka doncic
and trey young's in dallas
atlanta does that in a second atlanta
would never admit it publicly but they
would take luka doncic and that's the
thing i think trey young has been great
to me he's been the breakout star of
this playoffs but luca
is just at a different level you know
it's like the other night at barclays
center you're watching kevin durant and
you look at gianna synthetic combo and
be honest is everything that you'd want
in a player
just his dedication how much he wants to
improve
but he's a two-time mvp in the league
but kevin durant is just at a different
level just look at the shots that he
makes
the plays that he can make for other
players you love giannis but kevin
durant is better
you love trey young luka doncic and plus
the size of luka doncic
is a factor as well is ben simmons did
we overrate ben simmons
are we waiting for him to be the next
magic johnson and he's never going to be
the next
magic johnson i i think that part is
fair i think we do
tend to focus on the things that he
can't do which is shoot three pointers
i think he needs to get better clearly
shooting the free throws he was three
for ten
it's the same thing with antenna couple
everyone focuses on threes
they get bowed they go to the line knock
down the free throw so you get to these
points in a game
where it looks like ben simmons doesn't
want the ball and he doesn't want to
attack the basket
because he's worried about getting
ballots so i don't care about the
three-pointers but he needs to get
better
shooting from the free-throw line but he
can dominate on both ends of the court
he's big
i still think he's going to get better
you could tell that it's weighing on his
mind though getting fouled
the fans getting into it people talking
about his three-point shooting you could
tell that it's wearing on him a bit well
you saw that with lonzo ball
that he would be on the perimeter and he
could take a three-pointer or he could
take like a 20-footer and he would just
get they would just let him alone and
and you could played with him
now he became a little bit better but he
couldn't have been that much worse
i just ben simmons can't be a liability
it late in the game i know and you could
play off of him so when they're looking
to get back in the game and you watch it
last night he's dribbling down the court
you could lay off of him you know that
he's looking to pass the ball to
somebody else
so he's end up passing the ball to a guy
that isn't on his level as a player but
ben's not even thinking about shooting
three pointers it's a hurdle that he
needs to get over again i don't mind
that he doesn't attempt
10 a game but you might want to take two
or three a game because you're open and
you always have the ball in your hands
what do you think the lakers do in the
offseason
i mean health is going to have a lot to
do with it you know with lebron and
anthony davis but it was interesting
hearing magic johnson come out and
destroying
dennis schruter this happened that to me
is an american sports phenomenon we
always start blaming like the fourth
fifth and sixth best player
like it's their fault and it wasn't
anthony davis being hurt in lebron james
because when you look on paper when they
made those moves you thought schroeder
was an upgrade
over rondo just from a youth standpoint
and obviously has a lot more left in the
tank
manchester was a big time disappointment
so
even drummond remember when they picked
up drum and dan everyone thought well
this is unfair how come the lakers are
allowed to get a guy like this
so in the biggest game of their season
when anthony davis was on one leg
andre drummond doesn't even doesn't even
end up playing
so they need to do a better job of
filling those roster spots shooter will
be the big one
because maybe what they can do with him
is use him in a sign in trade
to bring back a player if they don't
want him anymore we had jalen rose on
last week
and he was so accurate in saying this
that in the offseason
a player when he's might leave be traded
sign
with somebody he's either going to
lakers or the knicks and then you know
damien lillard's name
came up and then all of a sudden it's
like could the knicks get damian lillard
here
what's the likelihood that damien
lillard is on another team next year
i still think with three years left on
his contract i'm still trying to build
around him and a lot of times
they obviously have already announced
that terry stotts is out so bringing a
new coach
could uh change things around i'm not
trading him unless i get blown away
think about how many first round picks
new orleans got
for jewel holiday think about all the
first round picks the houston rockets
got
for james harden so if you're making a
deal yes first round picks are going to
be a part of it which is something
that the knicks have but you want to get
a player back as well
i think eventually it could happen i
don't think this summer i'm keeping
damian lillard on my team
did the knicks have a successful season
100
definitely they did look at look at the
teams they finished ahead of
um atlanta on a tiebreaker miami
their talent's not better than those
teams their talent's not better than the
boston celtics so
the knicks overachieved during the
regular season dan because tom thibodeau
in a league where not all the teams and
all the stars played hard
every night the knicks played hard every
single night
i think randall played 70 or 71 games so
he was out there all the time but then
you saw julius randle in the playoffs
look at all the best teams whether it's
donovan mitchell
with utah devin booker with the phoenix
suns all the star players on those
individual
teams all had good performances in the
playoffs
julius randle scored 90 points in five
games
trae young scored 98 points at madison
square garden alone
so julius randle the guy that carried
them wasn't ready for the moment
but you know the dangerous part is now
the knicks have expectations
that's right like you know it's been
decades since they've had expectations
and in that city as you well know um
it can be pretty tough sledding when
they expect you now to be
a good team a top four top five seated
team
yeah they were the little engine that
could the owner stays out of it
now next season everyone's gonna look at
tom thibodeau and say all right now what
tom
we got the fourth seed you didn't want
to play off series so now all the
pressure is on you
for me the pressure is on the front
office during the off season
because the roster was essentially the
same except for adding a couple of
rookies and then they went out and got
derrick rose
who was a backup in detroit and became
really their best player
during the playoffs so the front office
which kind of stood pat
really didn't spend a lot of money the
knicks were well under the salary cap
it's up to them somehow to find a start
which is not easy to do that's why
that's why a lot of people in the
organization wanted gordon hayward
because those players don't become
available
that often because remember dan before
the season began it was his stream well
maybe jonas antetokounmpo will sign with
the knicks as a free agent then he ends
up re-signing
with the milwaukee bucks a lot of these
players end up resigning so when a guy
like that is available
you try to go for it he ends up going to
charlotte i get that he's hurt but he's
still a talented player
somehow the knicks have to improve their
talent because atlanta's talent was
better than the new york knicks talent
would you trade
chris thomas porzingis for ben simmons
who would you rather
if i were dallas i would do it i'm not
so sure
if i were philly i would do it because
he's still six foot nine can handle the
ball
and could defend and here's the other
thing it's durability and i like
kristaps but if you can't stay on the
court you're not doing me any good and
they already have a guy in embiid
i had an mvp vote i did not put him beat
in my top five because he only played in
51 games i mean come on now i think the
guy's terrific
but you know availability is important
as well as production that's why jokic
who played in 21 more games than than
embiid
i don't even think it's an argument yeah
i don't have a vote anymore but
i said i could not vote for james harden
because of what he did in houston
i i just i i love watching him
but what he did to that franchise he
showed up out of shape
he built a roster then dismantled a
roster and then wanted out
and i can't reward you because you
forced your way out to go to the nets
and you played well
i expect him to play well but he you
know he really damaged the franchise in
in the process
he he did and i didn't like the way that
he handled his departure from there and
i think you're 100
right you know as a professional you
need to show up a on time which he
didn't
in shape which he did then there were
stories that the owner was trying to
contact him during the off season he
wasn't returning the calls
if i go one day without returning my
boss's call there's a good chance i
won't be working there anymore
meanwhile you're getting paid like 20 30
million dollars you should return
with the call of your owner i did have
him
neck and neck with uh jokic and then i
was kind of taken off the hook by the
fact that he got hurt so
i didn't vote for anybody in my top five
who did not plan at least 60 games to me
that was the cutoff i can't vote for
guys playing
i can beat 51 i think lebron was about
between what was it 48 or 53 games so
that to me you have to play in the games
come on we have to have some standard
when we're voting for these awards
thank you frank great to talk to you
good talking dan good luck with the uh
emmy award
go pti sorry wait
wait wait wait those are my guys but
they've won it before
oh frank look at look at what you just
did to these guys
they pay me what do you want me to do i
know and i fill in on that show if you
have me filling for you then it'll be
they don't need they don't need another
win though
frank that's probably true i mean these
like this is the most important moment
in these guys lives
i apologize not when they had children
not when they got married
it's winning they want to get their
hands on on that that woman
that trophy all right i'll um you know
what i'll go for you guys the heck with
tony and mike what have they ever done
for me
they don't even care what i don't think
they do
i don't think they do thank you frank
thank you frank isola he's probably not
going to be co-hosting on pardon the
interruptions wow
you know wait can always come in here he
can sit in the chair if he wants to